it started before Dawn well more u-turns
say the Prime Minister the new
Chancellor moving fast to try to calm
the markets and a party in turmoil
Jeremy Hunt preparing his pitch to make
more than just a U-turn instead junking
the prime minister's entire policy plan
we will reverse almost all the tax
measures announced in the growth plan
three weeks ago that have not started
parliamentary legislation an enormous
decision announced by the new Chancellor
the person who's meant to be in charge
spent much of the day out of the public
eye the PM is detained on urgent
business
her absence on this occasion quite usual
but these far from normal times and the
opposition sees in the moment now it's
time for leaders to lead but where is
the prime minister the late is not for
turning up
a prime minister saying she's in charge
a chancellor who thinks he's the CEO and
she's just the chair yeah
to arriving to take the chair and listen
to her Chancellor her face fixed and
emotionless despite these tormented
times this government will take the
difficult decisions necessary to ensure
there is trust and confidence in our
national finances
that means decisions of eye-watering
difficulty
ditching almost all of that mini budget
announced just three weeks ago while the
energy price support deal cut back from
two years to just six months the Prime
Minister and I have reluctantly agreed
it would not be responsible to continue
exposing the public finances to
unlimited volatility in international
gas prices
so I'm announcing today a treasury-led
review into how we support energy bills
Beyond April next year we remain
completely committed to our mission to
go for growth but growth requires
confidence and stability but nothing for
this government is stable and they know
it I recognize we have made mistakes I'm
sorry for those mistakes
but I fixed the mistakes I've appointed
a new Chancellor we have restored
economic stability and fiscal discipline
and what I now want to do is go on and
deliver for the public we were elected
on the 2019 Manifesto I'm determined to
deliver on that but what's actually been
delivered are huge policy reversals that
you have jumped her mini budget and you
have also pretty much jumped a huge
chunk of her energy package they are the
policy platform that she stood on they
are the main measures of her as the
Prime Minister why is she still here
well um because I think we need to give
her a chance I don't think political
instability is the answer she's been
prime minister for only about five weeks
one of the most difficult aspects of
leadership is to be prepared to change
when you know things need to change and
she's done that will she be prime
minister by Christmas I believe so yes I
think a position
is untenable but many in her party her
own backbenches just do not agree you're
calling for her to go aren't you I think
it's her decision right now but I think
she doesn't go right now it will not be
her decision that agency will be taken
away from her how long do you think it
could be before that decision gets taken
one way or the other
a week or two tonight's a chance to
charm the cabinet does the Prime
Minister still have your support
ministers invited to number 10 for a
drinks reception is her position
recoverable
very good Friday
but she'll need far more than just that
it's traconomics dead sir if this pm has
any chance at all of surviving